what land what can we buy
that makes sense that meanwhile i have
another partner that does the baseball
cards with me
so i'm on ebay doing the cards okay cool
let's buy this let's try to buy a bunch
of these let's get these graded
and then you know i just look for any
opportunity that makes mathematical
sense
so you got your partner in the cards
would you say he's more knowledgeable
about what's going on in the card market
like at the specific moment well
basically he's like a retired attorney
and he does like
teach his kids this so yeah we're kind
of like we've been in the business maybe
for like 35 years
i was gonna say like he he's more of the
expert you're just the guy that's
pushing him to like do more deals make
more money and you're just well i think
we're both experts because we've both
been in the game and i've traveled the
nation
i did 35 big shows a year for like 10
years
and i've had a lot of athletes hung out
with celebrities bought and sold big
collections
you know i have a lot of crazy stories
too so the point of the matter is
the card game to me is more fun than the
real estate game
because you're picking and choosing and
even though it's rare
it's readily available when you deal
with real estate
it's like you're finding a needle in a
haystack
because the the the it's very limited
what do you mean when you say it even
though it's rare it's readily available
because ebay is a dumping ground a lot
of people want to realize
profits on stuff that they inherited
purchases of stuff that they had years
ago
so they're the black sheep of the
business because they're the dumpers
so um let's say a michael jordan rookie
in a certain grade is worth whatever
dollars as soon as it goes up in value
you'll see a lot of people just start
dumping on ebay
because they want to realize the profit
so a guy like me will come and hope they
drop
and then i'll start picking chipping
them off boom boom boom and then when
the dumpers are not dumping then i'll
start buying the buy it now to make the
values keep going up
because if i have a hundred of one item
and it's five thousand dollars
then i could create it to jump to ten
thousand now every single one of my
cards is now worth ten thousand each
that's how you make money so you don't
make money in
selling you make money and buying bro
have you ever seen that movie with adam
sandler
it's it's came out a couple years ago
where he's uh
i think he's in new york or somewhere
and he's the jewelry guy the jewelry guy
so he deals with kevin garnett and he's
he has an open yes
i mean that movie made no sense to me
because i used to own jewelry stores and
he needed money to pay debt
he had about a hundred thousand he had
about 50 000 grams of gold
and gold scraps out at the time gold was
2 000 an ounce
and 10 carat is 41 gold 14 carats 58
and 18 is 75 so he could have took the
gold and scrapped it
but i get the yeah he was on 47th street
in the diamond district
bro that [ __ ] was like a roach
a cockroach running around [ __ ]
robbing peter to pay paul
[ __ ] like well yeah the jewelry game
is a strong hustle because the diamonds
are the most manipulated item on earth
there's right
instant people right but you know that's
not my expertise even though i own a lot
of diamonds and i own a lot of jewelry
um yeah it's just but the card game is
different
because it seems like it's a similar
like kind of lifestyle though it seems
like it's
a similar mindset that dude's mindset
his [ __ ] just
eat sleep and breathe [ __ ] making
money and paying people back
and [ __ ] trying to rob this guy to
pay this guy and eventually he thinks
he's going to come out even but he's
he's [ __ ] he's just digging his own
grave the whole time the problem is he's
a compulsive gambler and
yeah you know it's just in life like a
lot of people
like to spend the money before they have
it yeah so at the same time they're not
really moving forward they're moving
backward
it's just like in the real estate
business any business people are
purchasing on what their payment is
going to be
not what the price is how do you think
these furniture store gives
60 months zero credit zero interest no
credit
because they're they're banking on the
fact that they need this necessity
and they're willing to pay that payment
they're just cheap right
so it's like when you when you're a
sharp and you a shark and you swim with
guppies
you're always going to make money due to
the fact that you see the
hidden value in people's necessities
how can you control that and when you're
dealing with sports cards and stuff like
that
you're banking on other people's egos
so you look at the guy you see the ego
and you already know how to play them
see that's the you know you see with my
point yeah everybody has a certain need
so the way to make money is just to have
a level head
and don't worry about anything and just
try to
figure out your opponent because
everybody's your opponent they're either
with you or against you
there's really no medium that's why i
only deal with the same amount of people
all the time
because a lot of people i deal with they
think they can take advantage of me
and those are my favorite people because
the only way they think they're gonna
get me is to do a deal with me
and when they do a deal with me the odds
of me losing are very low
so those are the people i like to work
with obviously wow
because people are edgy
pushy fearful spiteful hateful
those are the best people to do deals
with really
of course if they hate you that means
you love them
if somebody hated you you should love
them because they're jealous so they
have something against you
and if they're going to take time out of
their life their most precious asset
to have a negative thought of you you
must be in the back of their minds
somewhere right
so in their storage in their mental
capacity you're sitting there
see me i don't really hate anybody even
if you screwed me i still love you
because it doesn't make sense because
the the little thing you got from me i'm
gonna get it back
then at the same time i got that hidden
story on you for life
you know people i like to collect
stories more than i like to collect
anything else
is there any point where you can just
kind of like sit back and relax and kind
of stop the hustle
do you think that one day you're able to
stop hustling and just relax and enjoy
it
are you gonna think this is something
that's no i think it's something that's
embedded in my mind in my heart and in
my blood
because this is all i've ever known just
all i've ever did yeah i honestly i'm
never happy when i take a day off
because to me taking a day off is just a
waste of your mind
you know obviously you have kids and you
have your wife and you want to maintain
that that level of respect
and have fun but your mind never stops
so you know like i go to the gym in the
morning just to take a long drive just
to think about my next move
so when i get to push the weights or
punch the bag it's just basically a
routine to figure out what's next
yeah and you know like i honestly love
downturn markets because you actually
make more money because when you see
people's ribs showing then they get
nervous and they start dumping their
assets
when you're like when you're in a um
when you're in a market as we're seeing
right now
you know covet has affected a lot of
things and it's made a lot of people
filthy rich they never had any money
who has it made filthy rich well when
you look at
when you look at the world today you
look at these big companies who've
profited
off off off of this and you've seen like
companies like amazon and internet
companies yeah you know just basic
companies that you already know
the walmarts the amazons they're they're
making money out of people's fear
why do you think there was no toilet
paper because they would buy because
people
the media embedded in your mind fear
because that's what makes money for them
so as people fear you see their moves
and you understand the person by the
moves they make when they're in fear
see a guy like me and i don't mean to
act like i'm anybody special but i don't
fear anything except time
because it's the only thing that moves
so you have to follow you can't buy
exactly you know well i've we spoke on
that the other day you can't buy time
so that's got to be your most precious
asset everything else in life is
replaceable
you know obviously human beings are not
replaceable but every other
physical every other thing in life that
you could purchase is replaceable
getting back to the baseball cards
that's why they have such a high value
if they're extremely rare they're
unreplaceable so people want to buy them
because it brings back a point of their
childhood it brings the ego
out of them the same thing with pain
with anything anything that's rare has a
lot of value
yeah like real estate i like real estate
because
they don't create new dirt in reality
the only thing you're buying is the dirt
the actual building is just a liability
because it's depreciating every single
day
it's the dirt that's going up not the
building
i